abone ol
[Müzik]
mi
Evet farklı bir konsept kırmızı halı
kırmızı alın ortasında durmamız
gerekiyormuş biraz kendimi Film
Festivali'nde alan gibi hissettim böyle
kırmızı halılar falan ama ben özellikle
davet ettiğin için teşekkür ediyorum
Aslında çok yoğun bir tempo
içindeyiz takip edenleriniz
biliyorlardır Haftada iki maç 3 maç
sürekli seyahatler ama
gençlerle birlikte olmak benim için her
zaman çok büyük bir keyif gençlerle
deneyimleri paylaşmak onun içinde bugün
burada sizlerle keyifli bir sohbet
yapacağız
konsepti de söyledikleri zaman aslında
tam da
bizim yaptıklarımıza son
14 yıl içinde Yaşadıklarımıza uygun bir
konseptle birlikteyiz ribon yeniden
doğuş Evet aslında
Bunu sadece
bir pandemi döneminde bir
takımın yeniden doğuşuna da bağlamak Laz
bu sonra söyleyeyim size hayatın
içerisinde
bu ribon olayı yeniden doğuş olayım
aslında çok önemli çünkü bu bir kere
olmaz Evet bir kere doluyoruz işte de
doğal olarak Bak Dünyaya geliyoruz ama
ondan sonraki yaşantımız içerisinde
sürekli bir inişler çıkışlar yani
hayatta sürekli zirvede kalmak sürekli
olarak hep böyle yukarıya doğru bir
şekilde gitmek Zaman Zaman Zaman zaman
değil her zaman için mümkün olmuyor bu
her noktada böyle işte ekonomide de
böyle
Siyasette de böyle sizin öğrencilik
yaşamınızda da böyle bir zaman zaman
işler çok iyi gider fakat zaman zaman
dibe vurursunuz
çalışmıyorsunuz dur konsantrasyonunuzu
biliyordur ama bir olay olur hayatınızda
ve bir anda da ve kendinizi sanki
yeniden doğmuş yeniden odaklanmış
yeniden zirveye çıkmak için kendinize
bir güç görürsünüz İşte bizim
hayatımızda da aslında bu böyledir
antrenörlük mesleğinde de sürekli olarak
ya dünyanın en iyi antrenörleri bile en
iyi teknik direktörleri ile sürekli
olarak işte her sene şampiyon olan her
sene birinci olan her sene her yıl dünya
şampiyonu olamazsınız bizim mesleğimizde
bu böyledir p25 yıldır baş antrenörlük
yapıyorum
arkadaşların yaz önce yaptıkları
sonundaki gibi tabii ki Buradan sadece
başarılar konuşuluyor işte dört tane
farklı
awrupa Kupası 4 tane ayrı takımla
kazanılan Avrupa kupaları ve en sonunda
da en büyük kupa Euro Lig kupası Bunlar
konuşulan kısımlar başarılar ama bir de
tabii ki başarısızlıklarla var Yani
bazen de başarısı oluyorsunuz dibe
düşünüyorsunuz siz ve
mesleki kariyer olarak
çalıştırdığınız takım
Ondaki başarılar olarak dönemsel olarak
İşte o zamanda o zamanda
geri adım atmadan bu başarısızlıklardan
hatalardan yapmış olduğumuz hatalardan
bireysel olarak kulüp olarak ders
çıkartıp bunları bir fırsat haline
getirip yeniden şayet o gücünüz varsa
Men kendinize güveniyorsanız yeniden 1
Diriliş yeniden zirveye çıkan bir yolu
kendinize Hedef olarak seçmeniz
gerekiyor işte bizim size anlatacağım
hikaye de Aslında buradan başlıyor Ben
2017'deki 2012 17 yılları arasında
Galatasaray'da çalıştım onu da tak bir
arkadaşlığımız bir ve Galatasaray
basketbolun tarihinin en önemli
sonuçlarını elde ettik Bu dönemde 25 yıl
sonra Türkiye şampiyon olduk ilk kez
Galatasaray basketboluna Bir euro Kaplan
Avrupa'nın en büyük ikinci kupasını
kazandırdık
basketbolda Galatasaray'da çok büyük bir
heyecan yarattı Türkiye'de Galatasaray
basketbol takımının euroleague'e soktuk
Euro Lig'de play-off oynadık çeyrek
final oynadık fakat bir gün geldi bu beş
yılın sonunda ve Benim oradan ayrılmam
gerekti
Bu benim için büyük bir şey yoktu
açıkçası yani beş yıl çok büyük keyifler
yaşadığınız bitişli birliktelik
yaşadığınız web o kulüple özdeşleştiği
miz bir yerde oradan ayrılıyorsunuz bu
aslında bir
bu gibi gelişti yani sıfıra geliyorsunuz
bir anda boş nasılsınız aynı şekilde
Anadolu Efes Kulübü de yıllarca
Türkiye'de şampiyonluklar kazanmış
geçmişte koraç Kupası'nı kazanmış
Türkiye'de daha önceki adıyla Efes
Pilsen olarak daha sonra dolayı ses
olarak Türk basketbolunda bir Ekol olmuş
kulüp ama ben de daha önce
332 dönem daha mm ve 2002 yılları
arasında daha sonra 2009v 2010
yıllarında Ben de 2dönem gene
Anadolu Efes'te baş antrenörlük
yapmıştım ama mm
39 yılında benim
çalıştığım dönemde ki son Türkiye
şampiyonluğundan sonraki on yıl
dışarısında
de Anadolu Efes takımı bir türlü
yaptığı bu kadar yatırma rağmen
Türkiye'de şampiyon
olamamıştı ve bunun dışında da Avrupa'da
hep iddialı olmayı seven Anadolu Efes
Kulübü
2017 yılında Euroleague td16 takımda
Euro ligte sonuncu lad Emir atmıştı
sonucuydu ve
beni davet ettiler beni şarkılar o
dönemlerden takım çalıştırıyorum sezon
ortasıydı bu Tabii ki benim için
yeniden bir Diriliş ve bu dirilişi kendi
yetiştiğim Ben antrenörlüğü Anadolu Efes
kulübünde başlamıştım kendi yetiştiği
kulüp de bildiğim bir ortamda bu ve
hedefleri hep yüksek olan Ama son
yıllarda Bunu bir türlü yakalayamamış ve
artık dibe vurmuş olan bir kulüpte bunu
gerçekleştirebilirim bu şekilde yola
çıktık yani yeniden 2017'nin
sonunda sezon ortasında ama o sezon
benim elimde zaten kurulmuş olan bir
yapı vardı kurulmuş olan bir takım vardı
Ve açıkçası o sezonun sonunda başlarız
Zaten yarısı oynamıştı o sezonun
kaderini değiştiremedik ve biz gene Yuri
ben sonuncusunda almıştım sonuncu sırada
tamamladık
Ama işte o sonunculuk
zirveye giden yolun bir başlangıcıydı
Neden Çünkü bir önceki sezonun hemen
başında bütün bir kadroyu değiştirip
tamamen kendi inandığım oyuncular kendi
inandığım çalışma ekibini bir araya
getirip bir hedef koydum ve dedim ki bu
kulüp bu kadar bu basketbolda Avrupa
basketbolunda yatırım yapıyor oyuncu
yetiştiriyor her şey güzel Tesisler
güzel ortam güzel maddi olarak sağlanan
imkanlar gayet iyi o zaman yapılması
gereken tek bir şey var Buna inan
karakterli aç henüz şampiyonluk yaşamış
ama potansiyeli olan Avrupa'daki
oyuncuları bulmak scouting yapmak doğru
seçimler yapmak Türkiye'den beğendiğim
Takip ettiğim yeni oyuncular
keşfetmekte Sertaç Şanlı gibi bunlardan
bir tanesi yeni keşfedip yetiştirip
birlikte şampiyonluk yaşadığımız veda
sola biliyorsunuz Bu sezon başında da
Barcelona'ya transfer olan oyuncumuz
onun gibi 3-4 tane Türk oyuncuyla
beraber bir yola çıktık ve oyalı
çıkarken de şunu koyduk Aslında Elif
olarak da bitti şampiyonluğu koymadık
Yani bir anda dipten en zirveye çıkmak
Hayatta mümkün değil a çok kötü Biz
Anadolu efes'i yeniden Avrupa'da layık
olduğu Türk halkının o benimsediği
Türkiye'yi en iyi şekilde temsil eden
basketbol takımı haline geleceğiz ve bu
hedeflenen yola çıktıktan sonra da o
sezonun sonunda
2019 yılında ilk sezonda yani kurulan
3rd kendimizi
Ben 40 maç sonunda 40 maç bakın böyle
yani futbolda Bazen oluyor işte 54151
geçiyorsun şampiyonluğa finale
geliyorsun ayı 40 maç sonunda finalde
bulduk
fakat büyük bir sürpriz bu Belki de
Avrupa spor kamuoyunda dünya sporun da
nadir Olabilecek olan bir şeydi bu yani
Avrupa'da sonucu olan bir takımın Bir
sene sonra finalde şampiyonluk
mücadelesi vermesi bunu başardık ama o
tecrübesizlik l belki de o finale
gelmenin heyecanı çok büyük hedefi
gerçekleştirmenin on
güvenliğe o tatmini ile O gün o final
maçını kaybettik CSKA Moskova maçını
kaybettik İspanya'da düzenlenen finalde
ki bu final Euroleague final ipe dünyada
200'e yakın ülkede canlı olarak
seyredilen milyon O da milyar insanın
Seyr ettiği organizasyonda
bulunduk final oynadık 41'inci maçta
final oynadık ama kaybettik ama o gün
şunu gördük ki biz artık emeklemeye
başladık biz artık yürümeye başladık ya
emeklilik dönemine geçip artık yürümeye
başladık ha şimdi Bundan sonra artık
koşabiliriz kendimize güvenimiz var
komisyonumuz yerine geldi artık
koşabiliriz ve şunu gördük ki biz buraya
gelmeyi başarabildi yüksek ve biz o
kupayı orada görüp
o ulaşamadıysanız yok O zaman artık
bizim Tek hedefimiz kalmıştı yeniden
oraya gelmek ve o kupayı Bu kez kazanmak
ama işte hayatta bazen
karşımıza ya değişik engebeler
çıkabiliyor bir sonraki sezon aynı
kadroyu koyduk tekrardan yola çıktık
Euro Lig TV Euroleague domine etmeye
başladık neredeyse Yenilmez bir
durumdaydı yani Euro Lig tarihinin
galibiyet rekorunu kırdık 26 28 haftaya
geldiğimizde normal sezon 34 6/28
haftaya geldiğimizde 24 tane
galibiyetimiz vardı yani bu Euro Lig
tarihinde olmayan bir şey ve tüm
Avrupa Spor otoriteleri tarafından
Avrupa'nın en iyi basketbol oynayan en
Keyif veren basketbol oynayan ve
şampiyonluğun en büyük favorisi olarak
gösterilen olduk ya ben de açıkçası hep
bunu söylüyorum Yani bir NBA takım gibi
oynuyoruz gelene geçene 15 ve bu sayı
farklarla yani Barcelona sından tuttu
işte Panathinaikos Olympiakos Real
Madrid kimse bize rakip olamıyordu
içeride dışarıda herkese gidiyorduk Ama
karşımıza hiç beklemediğimiz bir rakip
çıktı pandemi ve bir anda tüm dünyada
olduğu gibi bu bizi de vurdu ve
biliyorsunuz tüm sportif müsabakalar
durduruldu
ta bizim için bu büyük bir şey yoktu Bir
taraftan Yani kendi sağlığımız
oyuncularımızın sağlığı ailemizin
sağlığı dünyanın sonu gelmişti bu
psikolojik içerisine ama bir taraftan da
çok büyük hedefi yakalamak üzereyken
Evet iki kişi olarak ben yıllarca bütün
kupaları kazanmış işte 19 Türkiye'de
5-6 tane şampiyonluk Türkiye kupaları
Cumhurbaşkanlığı kupaları Avrupa'daki
bütün kupaları kazanmış Ama şöyle bir
eleştiri vardı ya ergen atamazsan bütün
kupaları Kazandım da en büyük kupa orada
o ulaşamazsın diye ona ulaşmaya bu kadar
yakınken bir anda pandemi durdurulan
başlar Evet ilk bir iki ay her şeye
rağmen biz takım olarak bak
oyuncularımızı gruplara ayırıp üçerli
dörderli gruplara ayırıp salona getirdik
Bütün Türkiye'de Herkes
bu müsabakalar bırakmışken Biz
oyuncularımıza o İnançla antrenman
yaptırmaya devam ettik Çünkü şuna
inanıyorduk Yani bu pandemic 2 3 ay evet
bir şok olacak ama Yaz ayları geldiğinde
bu rahatlar sonunda bu Euro likte
tamamlanır Biz de o hedefimize Ulaşırız
diye ama olmadı Evet pandemi rahatladı
birçok müsabaka Avrupa'da birçok
organizasyon yapıldı NBA maçları
tamamlandı bir fanus şeklinde yapıldı
Türkiye Ligi'nde de futbol ligleri
oynandı
Avrupa UEFA Şampiyonlar Ligi oy kullandı
ama Eurolig bir karar verdi ve dedi ki
ben bu organizasyonu bu sene
tamamlayacağım
veya sezon ilan ettim evinize teşekkür
ediyoruz bir sonraki sezon yeniden
başlayacağız i Şimdi siz bu şoku
düşünebiliyor musunuz Yani maçların
yüzde sekseni oynamış sınız
şampiyonluğun en büyük sayısız ve
teşekkür bile edilmedi ve bir hayatta
Euroleague bir mesaj yayınladı ya nefes
takımına üzgünüz bu kadar büyük bir çaba
sarf ettiler
ama biz Nebi onları ödül vereceğiz Ne ne
işte bugün birincisi ilan edeceğiz ne
şampiyon ilan edeceğiz Nefize de masa
başında
Bizim şampiyonluk güme gitti Ama bu bize
bir sonraki sezon yani Geçtiğimiz sezon
şampiyon olduğumuz sezonun en büyük
motivasyonu verdi bu çünkü biz yeniden
başlayacak olsak da yeniden başlayacak
olsakta kadromuzun tamamını korur burada
tabi kulüpte büyük küçük oyunu
sözleşmeleri bitti oyuncularda iyi
oynamışlar hepsi geçen sezonun Bir
önceki sezonun flaş takımı bütün
Avrupa'dan Hatta NBA den teklifler
geliyor larımızı ama kulüp olarak buna
İnandık
fedakârlıkta bulunduk maddi fedakarlık
ya bulunduk oyuncularımız fedakarlık da
bulunduğu takımlar ayrılmak istemediler
ve o masa başında kaybettiğimiz
şampiyonluğu elde etmek için bu
parolayla yeniden yola çıktık tek bir
hedefimiz vardı kendimize tek bir hedef
koyduk ona şampiyonluk Bunun dışında
hiçbir şey bizi tatmin edemezdi Şimdi
burada tabii ki en önemli nokta şu Biz
orada demoralize olup ya Biz şampiyon
olurduk ama bu işte elimiz da gitti Bir
daha bunu yakalayabilir miyiz şimdi
rakipler de güçlendi gördüler kişi nefes
takımı Avrupa'nın en iyi herkes transfer
yaptı ayır o sezonun başında da biz
hedefi bi koymaktan çekinmedi ko bize
yapılan haksızlığı bir motivasyon unsuru
olarak önümüze koyduk ve o büyük Hedef
doğrultusunda yola çıktık hedefimiz
şampiyonluk to
başarıya gitmek için arkadaşlar başarıya
gitmek için bir kere
B gerçekleri kabul etmemiz gerekiyor
Evet bu hayatımızın bir gerçeği de bu
bizim bir gerçeğimiz de elimizden O
büyük hayalimiz alınmıştı ama bir
gerçeğimiz vardı ki bizim bunu
başarabilecek olan gücümüz vardı o zaman
bu gücümüze sahip çıkmamız gerekiyordu
Ve ve çalışmayı en yoğun şekilde devam
edip Çünkü karşınıza gene önümüzde Yani
tekrardan o finale gelme O nereden 40
tane maç oynamamız gerekiyordu İşte biz
geçen sene bu 40 tane maçı
yeniden oynadık önce normal sezonda
normal sezonu 18 takım arasında üçüncü
sırada bitirdik altı olan Real Madrid'le
eşleşti ki Real Madrid'de turnuvanın
şampiyonluğun en büyük adaylarından bir
tanesi 7 kötü bir sezon geçirdiler ve
maalesef t
t off larda 36 eşleştiği için Aslında
şampiyonluğun en güçlü rakiplerinden bir
tanesiyle biz playoff'ta eşleşmiş olduk
Bu da çok ciddi bir engel de bizim için
şampiyonluğa giden yolda ve Hakikaten de
kolay olmadı İstanbul'daki maçları
farklı kazandık ama oraya gittiğimiz
zaman bir anda hedefe doğru çok
yaklaşmışken 15 sayı öndeyken 3 dakika
kala açık kaybettik 2-0 öndeyken durumu
2-1 oldu bu ve onlar Özgüven geldi
karşınıza Real Madrid var şampiyonluk
için yola çıkan bir takım var ve üçüncü
başına kaybettik orada yine benzer
şekilde Biz kazanırken 22 oldu 22 olduğu
zaman İstanbul'daki son maç Hedef büyük
hedefimiz var ama açmamız gereken de çok
büyük bir engel var
En sonunda bu engeli de hem yaptığımız
çalışmayla hem de inancımızın işte Son
50 saniye kadar crossbows limonun attığı
sol köşeden çok zor bir üçlük var Maçı
kopartan büyümüştük Belki de normal
şartlarda 10 tane atsa öyle düştük ancak
bir tanesi iki tanesi girer O gün o sayı
oldu O gün o neden sayı oldu
biliyormusunuz çünkü biz olarak etmiştik
Çünkü biz oraya gelmeyi hak etmiştik ve
ve o basketten Biz kendimizi yeniden
4'lü finaller de bulduk Bu sefer de
karşımızda normal sezon iki sırada
bitiren son onbeş yılda 14 tane final
oynayan yedi tane 8 tane tam şu anda
söyleyemeyeceğim şampiyonluğu olan çsyk
moskovayla yarı finalde karşılaştık
finalde 2019'da kaybettiğimiz CSKA
Moskova bu sefer yarı finaldeki
rakibiniz dedi
çok üstün bir oyundan sonra maçı domine
ettik Yani 15-16 sayılara çıkardık Ama
son periyotta bir anda o heyecan herkese
heyecan yaklaştılar yaklaştılar ve Maçın
son topunu iki saniye kala onlar
kullandılar sayıya Çeviremedi ler Bu bir
tesadüf müydü ve atan oyuncuları da
maçın en değerli oyuncusu with Driver
Driver değildi çünkü biz ona hak
etmiştik o atış basket olmadı Ve bir
Finale kaldık bir eldeki rakibimiz de bu
sefer Allah herkesin
şampiyonlukta çok büyük
favorisi olan Barcelona ydı Ama artık
biz oraya gelmiştik biz artık işte o
dipten zirveye yeniden
çıkmış ve artık o kupayı orada
bırakmayacak tık ve Neticede
o final maçının sonunda Yani bir sezonun
41'inci maçta Bu kez o kupaya ulaşmayı
başardık ve bu işte bir ribon yeniden
doğuş to üç sene içerisinde en dipten
aşama aşama Avrupa'nın en büyük kupasına
ulaşmayı başarmış tık bunu yaparken de
kendimize olan güvenimiz de kurduğumuz
kadrodaki oyuncularımızın karakteriyle
sezon boyunda boyunca yapmış olduğumuz
çalışmaların bütün ekibin hep birlikte
abone olup taraftarımızın inancıyla
Sinerji dan kazanılan bir şampiyonluk
oldu ama şimdi bu şampiyonluk devam
edebilecek mi onuda göreceğiz ona da
önümüzdeki günlerde kısa bir zaman sonra
bunu da elde etmiş olacağız Evet tam 15
dakika yı doğru bir şekilde tamamladım
hepinize teşekkür ederim